انت بعدها على راس السعه وهذا موجز لاهم
الانبا نفى رئيس الحكومه الباكستانيه
الشيخ باز شريف ايا صله له او لوزير
الداخليه او مسؤولين في المخابرات
بمحاولات الاغتيال الفاشله لرئيس الحكومه
المقارنه عمران خان وقال الى تحقيقات
كفيله باظهار حقيقه
هذا وكان رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان
قد اتهم رئيسا الوزراء الحالي بالتورته في
محاوله اغتياله مشيرا الى انه من غير
الممكن تحقيق العداله ما لم تتم اقالته
رفقه وزير الداخليه واحد جنرالات جهاز
الاستخبارات العسكريه
وقد رفض الجيش اتهامات عمران خان وعصفها
بالباطله ودعا الجيش الحكومه لاجراء تحقيق
الموسع في محاوله في محاوله الاعتداء على
خانه
على موقع
تقدم القوات الروسيه شمال مطار المدينه
وقال الزعيم الانفصاليين في دمشق الى
الجيش الروسي على وشك السيطره على بلده
السلطات المواليه لروسيا رجاء نحو السبع
مئه من سكان مدينه
بعمليه الاجزاء تجري بشكل الزابي وسيتم
نقل السكان الى تباسي وذلك للحفاظ على
حياتهم من خطر اي هجوم اوكرانيا محتمل
وفقا تعبيره
حضرها المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الاوكرانيه
طهران من تبيعات دعمها لموسكو وقال ان على
طهران ان تدرك ان عواقب التواطئ في جرائم
العدوان الروسي ضد اوكرانيا سوف تفوق
بكثير فوائده دعم روسيا حسب تعبيره وكان
وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه قال ان بلاده
سلمت روسيا عددا محدودا من الطائرات
المسيره قبل اشهر من بدايه الحرب في
اوكرانيا واضاف الوزير انا طهران اذا
تاكدت من ان روسيا استخدمت المسيرات
الايرانيه في حرب اوكرانيا فسيكون لديها
رده فعل اتجاه هذه المساله
علنا الجيش الكوري الجنوبيه لكوريا
الشماليه اطلقت اربعه صواريخ بالستيه
قصيره المدى باتجاه البحر
لتجاربها الصاروخيه هذا الاسبوع
الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه تدريبات
استمرت سته ايام وشاركت في هذه التدريبات
نحو 240 طائره عسكريه واثرتان من القاذفات
الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه من طراز وانبي